عشره ايام تفصلنا عن الذكرى السنويه
الاولى للحرب في اوكرانيا والتي لا يبدو
ان نهايتها تلوح في الافق الناتو يواصل
الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا الا ان ذخيرته قد
تنفذ خلال ايام ان خاض حربا بحسب تقرير
لينوزويك نيوزويك نقلت عن مسؤولين غربيين
قولهم ان الناتو سيطلب من الاعضاء تعويض
الامدادات المنخفضه عبر زياده الانتاج
النقص بحسب مصادر نيوزويك يكمن في المقام
الاول في القذائف المستخدمه في مدافع
الهاوجر وصواريخ هاي مارس وذخائر انظمه
الدفاع مثل الامريكيه بريطانيا مثلا بدات
بالفعل في اتخاذ خطوات للتعويض عن الاسلحه
في ديسمبر اعلن وزير الدفاع ان وزرته
وافقت على خطه لانتاج المزيد من الذخيره
المضاده للدبابات في الولايات المتحده
كشفت وزاره الدفاع عن وجود خطط لتجديد
امداداتها وزيادات مخزون الاسلحه اليوم
ايضا اكد وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن
ان بلاده ستواصل دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا
[موسيقى]
سنبحث في مبادرات صناعيه تضمن استمراريه
دعمنا لاوكرانيا على المدى البعيد ايضا
سنبحث في مسؤوليات المتعلقه بالدعم الامني
الذي نقدمه لاوكرانيا والذي بلغ مستويات
تاريخيه اوكرانيا ملتزمه بان الدعم
العسكري الذي تتلقاه سيصل الى الجنود
الاوكرانيين على الجبهات هذا الاجتماع
ياتي في وقت حرج الكرملين ما زال يراهن ان
بمقدوره ان يفرقنا لكن بعد عام من الحرب
مازلنا متحدين كما كنا سابقا
الامين العام للناتو
ينسدد على ان الحلفه وشركائه سيواصلون دعم
اوكرانيا كي تضمن الانتصار في الحرب
[موسيقى]
الاسبوع المقبل الذكرى الاولى للحرب في
اوكرانيا والغزو الروسي لا نرى اي مؤشرات
على ان الرئيس بوتين يستعد للسلام بل
العكس يستعد لمواصله الحرب وشن هجمات
جديده من المهم ان يقدم الحلفاء وشركاء
الناتو المزيد من الدعم لاوكرانيا سنعالج
الاحتياجات العاجله لزياده الدعم بينها
توفير المزيد من الاسلحه والذخيره وتقويه
صناعه الدفاع وتجديد المخزون العسكري يجب
ان تحصل اوكرانيا على اسلحه تضمن انتصارها